hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from yesterday's leeches
titled arena I didn't get a chance to
catch any of the game says I had a
tournament of my own we had a Boots
tournament in my chess club I'm very
happy to announce that I was able to win
first place even though I was a third
seed at the tournament and there you
have it there's my shiny trophy here you
can see most of you don't speak Croatian
but you know just in case there you have
it
alright now that that we've gotten that
out of the way we usually don't show
bullet games but it's way when it's
played at this level between all eras
and Magnus that their board game is of
higher quality than most of ours class
our classical games and it's Sunday the
positions that arise are really
interesting so we're gonna take a look
at them this is the last game from
glitches titled array arena
between the two of them so it's the last
game but both of them played I believe
so I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it let's
check it out now it has a width the
white pieces opens with E for ya we have
c5 Magnus of course goes for his
Sicilian defense we have Knight of three
sorry about that
we have Knight to c6 and now Knight to
c3 still postponing to push d4 but it's
it's not a problem you could always do
this maybe even to confuse your opponent
a little bit with east sucks and only
now before we have C captures Knight
captures and a six so the time on of
variation is on the board with Bishop to
e3 and the knight to f6 now with a three
by Allah days on end
Queen to c7 so this is all standard
stuff F for viola days and now there are
a few moves that are often played in
this position d5 is a non move in this
position knife captors and e4 is a non
move most played move is d6 and consider
the strongest by far but here Magnus
goes for b5 and it is a new move in the
position so already as of move 8 we have
a completely new game and this this line
instead of going for d6 or d5 or just
captures allows all areas of this ePHI
move which
of course he goes for so Magnus trades
on d4 nightcap for sandy for Bishop
captures and now you could go for a
night to default and allowed the
doubling of the points but Magnus
prefers nights the g8 he wants the
Riemann over the night at the f5 via the
h6 square so and also the ship to b7 is
coming so ali reza prepares to counter
that with Bishop to e2 Bishop to d7 and
now brush up to f3 countering that
Bishop we have night to h6 going for
that f5 square there you will harass the
bishop on d4 from there and now Knight
to e4 an excellent square for the knight
Magnus definitely doesn't want to give
up the light square bishop to get rid of
this night and at some point if maybe
this bishop moves maybe ideas like
Knight to d6 where it will come to mind
but ok Knights the f5 by Magnus is going
after the bishop now the shabak the f2
and now maybe not immediately but at
some point maybe some g4 idea dislodging
the knife from the defense of d6 fall by
Knight to d6 could be played so Magnus
prevents it with h5 and okay we need to
continuing development preparing the
castle either King side or Queen side
depending on what Magnus plays and now
look the c8 threatening to pick up the
pawn here
so c3 always our defensive end now
finally d5 and here of course you either
move the knight which is something you
don't want to do you you want to capture
on d6
as if you allow this d5 pawn to stay
here then it's a well it's doubtful what
your life's work Bishop will be will be
even doing so oh it is a captures on
pass on with it captures and d6 on pass
on Knight captures and e6 we have
castles now and Magnus just trades
everything Knight captures the Bishop
captures the bishop characters and the
Queen captures on e4 and Bishop to d6
goes after the f4 pawn and his King is
still in the center of the board so
ideas like f5 do come to mind with ideas
are just busting open the position here
but then you allow Bishop captures on h2
with check and four for a bull again not
something you want to go into so first
Bishop to d4 just developing now the
rook and
the Queen defend the e4 pawn and you
already go for the g7 pawn
magna Magnus castles and now comes route
81 and Alireza
forces are now fully operational
so rook FD 8 by Magnus and King to h1 at
samples at some point this this diagonal
might might come under Carson's control
so you don't want your king here king h1
always a useful move and Bishop to c5
Magnus wants to trade all of the old
lowlife pieces Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Queen back to f3 with
ideas of maybe pushing f5 at some point
so g6 Magnus doesn't allow it and now
rook the e5 a nice rook lifts with Queen
to c4 and now comes Luke if the e1
probably Alireza was considering stuff
like maybe Queen g3 with ideas of rook
captures here so Magnus puts pressure on
the rook here so look Fe one other it
has a doubles on the e-file and now rook
C to d8 rook the other rook should have
gone to the D file here Magnus Magnusson
out how it is at this f5 move a little I
didn't play it or because it's not all
that clear what you gain point is you
cannot capture because you lose the rook
and if you capture with the G pond and
Queen captures an h5 but still black
doesn't have white doesn't have much
here but it is something but instead all
eras are prepared with Queen to g3 now
there are ideas of either rook captures
here or just f5 now will be strong so
first rook to d3 putting pressure on all
races Queen Queen to g5 now still with
ideas of f5 because you will not be able
to capture with it with either pawn and
now rook eat the da Magnus just doubles
up on the defiled prepares rook to d1 he
wants to trade a pair of rooks and well
reduce really reduces the pressure in
the position so when one of the rooks is
exchanged then he's just gonna be he's
just gonna have a better position so h3
Ali Reza makes some breathing room for
the king we have looked at d1 and now
King h2 still not interested in
capturing
the other worked to come to the first
friend we have Queen to b3 now keeping
an eye keeping an eye on the f5 square
but now other reza sets sets a very nice
trap for for Magna C plays rook one to
e3 and now it's a it's a really
interesting position what do you what do
you what do you play here would you
what don't you play here it's hard to
say because it's too complicated for for
such a short time format but we will get
back to this position a point is Magnus
played the Queen - Queen to d2 you had
to play something like Queen b1 or Queen
to d7 to either keep an eye on the g6
pawn or to keep an eye on the g7 square
but we're gonna return to that just
because it's super interesting
so here Magnus played Queen to d2 but it
doesn't work feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
for ali reza while i give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on taking
advantage of the only mistake magnus
made in the game and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's of
course rook captures on e6 that's the
point this is what all it has a plate
and now you have to capture the room
it's not there's not much you can do for
example if 25 euro for a queen trade
route captures and g6 is coming and now
you're already down two points so you
might as well capture the rook and now
Queen captures in g6 and you're just
getting made it King to f8 you're gonna
get Queen h6 check King f7 Queen h7
checking of six Queen east 7 check now
forcing the king down the board king g6
and now rook to e6 with check either
winning the Queen which will be
sufficient for a victory or king of five
and then just Queen to f6 is checkmate
so after rook captures on e6 of course
Magnus captured the rook but now it's a
Queen captures on g6 King the f8 and now
comes Queen to f6 check and again if you
go to eat it's not not much better rook
captures here and you are getting made
adhere king d7 rookie 7 checking has to
go back Queen captures an a6 check King
here and Queen delivers mate
so Magnus went nuts to eat but rather to
g8 but here Ali Reza just played rook to
G
three check and it was in this position
that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and well we are we are going to discuss
the standings a little bit because it's
also very interesting
if King 2h7 didn't just win kappa Queen
to g7 is made and there are no other
moves King h7 is the only move for
Magnus of course he resigned here but
now I just want to return to that
position because like I said it's
extremely interesting after Ali Reza
played this rook one is to remove and
Magnus played Queen to d2 had Magnus
played the Queen to be one then it's a
it holds but it's it's remarkable how it
holds problem is you still face rook
captures on e6f captures an e6 and now
rook captures on e6 with the idea of
capturing here
as the Queen was guarding the g6 square
but now you get Luke to h1 with check
King g3 and now rook to d7
that's the point but finding this would
be would be crazy even in a classical
game from that position to see this rook
d7 the only the only move that works for
black because now the point is if you go
rook captures here you just capture it
with the Queen Queen captures and the
rook g7 picks up the Queen so captures
captures and black is just upper rook so
the only thing you could do after rook
to d7 this beautiful defensive idea is
actually kink the h4 not allowing after
this trade happens a four-block to pick
up your queen but now black has rug g7
now the g6 pawn is defended twice and
black is up a whole rook but White has a
perpetual rook e8 check King h7 you get
Queen to d8 threatening mate and now
rook to f7 so these are these are very
unique moves and it's really crazy that
such a position would happen in a bullet
game rook a trait check King g7 Queen to
GA to chair King of 6 and now we have a
perpetual after a Queen to d8 check
because if you go down the board you're
getting mated so we have to go back and
now it's just a nice perpetual so really
really impressive stuff and really in
this position finding this well even in
a classical game not not happening well
you would definitely play it and then
maybe find it after I you would not play
this in class became of course and a lot
of this but
it's really really impressive stuff so
yeah like I said I do hope you enjoyed
it and these are the standings after the
leeches titled arena sorry I just have
to make it a little bit smaller as you
can see a Larissa won first place a
Magnus won second place and Penguin won
third place but it was it was extremely
close you see first Magnus was on a
streak and then Magnus lost the last
five games and ali reza on the other
hand won the last five games and out of
those five i think two of them were
against Magnus and he beat Magnus in
both of the in both of them so if you
take those well for those 20 points
that's basically it it was it was really
intense up until the last minute and
otherwise I was able to really put it in
in in a better gear in the end of the
tournament and and win the tournament
with a would have a very nice point lead
I had a head of everyone including
Magnus so there we have it for the title
arena March of 2020 unleashes first
place now there is a second dr. Victor
Stein
that's Magnus Carlsen a third penguin GM
and Andrew tank then fee glued and don't
know who that is
then federic of 93 wizard 98 saviours of
eloquence 7th house martell innate
freedom master then Grandmaster Nico
serene in ninth and international master
mini Romania in 10th place so III
measuring was a it was a great
tournament but yeah III couldn't catch
any of the game so that's why I decided
to show you one and I will put a link to
the tournament in the description below
if you want to check out some of the
games maybe so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank very much murdoch Johan off life
Steve Hansen bill Parkinson and Joel
Siegel for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Paul Morphy saga
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever
whatever else happens in the chess world
so I think oh I will see you soon and
heaven
receiver Sunday